tonight we are leaving the European  Union for many people this is an  astonishing moment of hope a moment they  thought would never come and there are  many of course who feel a sense of  anxiety and loss and then there's a  third group perhaps the beast who had  started to worry that the whole  political wrangle would never come to an  end  I understand all those feelings and our  job as the government my job is to bring  this country together now and take us  forward the most important thing to say  tonight is that this is not an end but a  beginning this is the moment when the  dawn breaks and the curtain goes up on a  new act in our great national drama